foreign
welcome to Game On Vegas this is the
city's top rated Sunday night Sports
show thank you for spending your evening
with us right here on channel 8. we've
got a terrific show lined up of course
we'll open up the sports Vault peek
inside share some history we've also got
a couple of Las Vegas Golf Hall of Fame
inductees in studio they've met
presidents entertainers Legends of the
games so that's going to be a lot of fun
it's also a game one of the WNBA finals
the house was packed over at Mandalay
Bay fans were showing up and they were
loud we'll take you to the game one
how'd the MVP do tonight it's the best
of five and game one did not disappoint
it was a thriller we'll show you how the
game unfolded Kevin Martin was Courtside
for all those big shots but tonight we
begin with the Raiders and the Chargers
from Sofi Stadium a packed palace with
about half the crowd cheering for the
silver and black writer Nation showing
up in force all that off-season
anticipation waiting to see the college
buddies back on the field playing for
the same team now great scene today
we're talking about Cocker Devonte by
the way they were reunited oh it's great
we'll have more on that in just a minute
maybe this team though needs to play a
little bit more of those preseason games
they can't simulate the speeding
practice or those joint practices
Raiders almost score pass behind Waller
so they settle for three it's tied at
three but then the Chargers go to work
Justin Herbert providing uh this pass
here what a talent this guy is he's
awesome the former Duck throwing a pair
of first half touchdowns from inside the
five it's 17-3 at the half Las Vegas
though opened the game with a scoring
Drive they open the second half with a
scoring drive car 18 yards to Brandon
Bolton mistakes would hurt the Raiders
though car was sacked five times three
by his friend Khalil Mack but they're
still in the game Raiders again late in
the fourth car two defonte Adams 10
catches 141 yards and that touchdown
they got back into this thing they
needed the ball back they got it back
they needed the touchdown didn't happen
Chargers hang on winning
24-19 car picked off three times and
that offensive line is certainly a work
in progress address
having them out there it wasn't you know
I mean first play we go and go right to
him you know and it wasn't like some big
celebration you know it was just like
all right well next time you know next
one you know I've gone thousands of
footballs in my life and so
um it's exciting to play with him but
um he'll tell you like I won't you know
we just want to win
you know before you can win you got to
figure out how to not lose the game and
that starts with turnovers and not
giving up big plays and look it's
opening day there's a lot that goes on
and I appreciate the fight that our team
showed and the grit that we had
um you know you fall behind by a couple
scores and then you have the ball in the
fourth quarter with a chance to win so
that's the National Football League
though
it certainly is boy a talented team too
one final word now from the Sofi Stadium
and let's toss it over to Ron Futrell
so tough day for the Raiders their
defense one of the price Buster defense
looked good certainly at times in
stopping the high-powered offense of the
LA Chargers here by the way I do want to
mention here in La very muggy field here
and and there's no there's no air
conditioning in this Stadium you want to
let your fans know this if you come to
Sofi Stadium no air conditioning here
because even though it has a roof it is
exposed on the sides so it had to be
tough conditions certainly for the
players for the fans for everybody
involved well it's a muggy day as I
mentioned here in L.A but the Raiders
start the season with a loss to the
Chargers a tough one to get ready for
Arizona next week where there is air
conditioning in Allegiant Stadium
reporting from Sofi Ron Futrell a Sports
now all right thank you very much Ron
yes there will be air conditioning next
week against Arizona one more note from
today by the way we debuted our new show
called Sports wrap each and every Sunday
coming out of the Raiders games and each
and every Sunday sports wrap with our
guest expert and former Super Bowl
winning quarterback Jay Schrader
there are still big questions there a
lot of pressure sacks it turned into
turnovers and uh for the Raiders and you
can't do that you got to get that
cleaned up you know we were also
thinking we talked about the hunter
Renfro the Darren Waller and the Devonte
Adams connection with Carr
um it was I think the third period or
with about three and a half minutes ago
before Renfro even got a touch yeah and
I I don't think that was planned I think
it just happened because of the game but
they've got to get that cleaned up he's
that guy that continues drives you got
to get him involved you got to get
Hunter involved he's the guy that's
going to make that third and three catch
and you know and get you that uh tough
yardage in there so they'll get that
cleaned up and hopefully things will
start to turn around you know Jay we
were talking about this a half hour ago
or so that really they had four
preseason games but none of these guys
played in that preseason so it kind of
showed today it really did yeah there
was a little rust uh game speed is
always different you know you can go
through practice and practice and
practice once you get on the game I mean
it's like bullets and they're flying
around and you know I don't care what
you do in practice you can't simulate
Joey Bosa and Khalil Mack coming off the
edge that's that's a different deal and
uh so it showed there today but you know
one of the right spots though really was
Devonte Adams when you look at this guy
over the course of the Season what these
two are going to do he got the touchdown
pass and got the big yardage here but
that's going to be special it is going
to be special Devonta is just a special
athlete there's no question about it he
has made himself probably the best best
receiver in the game right now all
around I think and I think he proved
everybody today just in in the first why
they gave up you know the two picks in
the draft picks and everything else he
he is a special player